cucs voilà donc le temps de ce film le
tueur à gages jean rochefort qui donne
une première leçon à son assistant
débutants guillaume depardieu
alors c'est vrai ce qu'on a tout de
suite dans ce film dès les premières
images c'est l'humour qui n'est pas
habituel dans le cinéma français
voilà c'est un ton pierre salvadori je
crois un immense talent je suis très
heureux d'avoir fait ce premier film
c'est un film avec une vérité dans
l'absurde on peut trouver des
parrainages avec les monty python avec
d'autres gens aussi plus j'ai toujours
moi a apprécié et j'ai eu une rencontre
et je trouve que il s'est passé beaucoup
de choses dans ce siècle et bien sûr le
cinéma est le miroir de tous ces
événements qui se sont passés depuis que
moi je suis sur cette planète en votre
compagnie et par exemple on peut dire
que quand j'ai des enfants quand une
jeune de femme éprouvé un sentiment
amoureux on la voyait regarder avec
componction à bouquet de violettes
ensuite juste après la guerre elle
tombée en larmes après un repas en
disant je crois que j'aime bernard et
c'était daniel gélin convoyait
bouleversé et il ya eu riz après le
féminisme juste avant le féminisme plus
exactement là la jeune première recevait
une lourde de gifle est tombé dans les
bras de son amant et main et maintenant
salvatori voilà comment ça se passe et
c'est la même chose c'est de l'amour si
le besoin de l'autre elle entre dans la
chambre de guillaume depardieu est lui
bel son pantalon de pyjama il dit mais
qu'est ce que vous faites une fellation
j'enterre ma vie de jeune fille mais il
y a toujours ce besoin de l'autre et ce
besoin d'amour et ça ça me passionne
dans l'entreprise et dont ce que le
cinéma devient le miroir de notre époque
et notre société alors c'est très
intéressant parce qu'avec pâte à choux
et vous vous êtes les deux seuls adultes
si je puis dire de ce film pratiquement
parce que c'est un film de jeunes le
réalisateur très jeune il a moins de 30
ans le producteur pareil marie
trintignant guillaume depardieu très
jeune des enfants
oui alors pourquoi ils font appel à vous
eh bien ma bolivar est qu'il y paraît
que les jeunes vous demande beaucoup
oui oui mais en ce moment je j'espère
rencontrer beaucoup de pierre salvadori
j'espère refaire des films avec
salvadori mais ben oui peut-être
peut-être que
que j'écoute jules goux j'ai le goût
d'écouter et j'ai le goût de recevoir
des autres ce que souvent les gens de ma
génération ne font pas ils parlent
beaucoup et n'écoute pas les autres je
pense que c'est une des raisons qui vous
écoutent oui oui dans le cas de pierre
salvadori on a été dans une complicité
absolument merveilleuse ce film très
très drôle correspond beaucoup à un
esprit que j'aime profondément et que
j'ai essayé très modestement d'imposer
ou en tout cas de faire connaître ces
derniers temps c'est à dire la drôlerie
dans la plausibilité être plausible dans
la cocasserie alors je vous interromps
jean rochefort je pense qu'on va pouvoir
aller maintenant à stuttgart car il est
temps maintenant de retrouver les
athlètes qui court le 100 m